foreign
this is
if I can get that to start again
foreign
try to get that live stream going
all right
one more time
third time's the term thank you and
Welcome to our LinkedIn live audience
our YouTube live audience and of course
everyone here on Zoom
and
we have a presentation here how to
become a business analyst in just six
months with
IIT rookie
uh in collaboration with IBM my name is
Stuart Creek I am with simply learn we
are the delivery partner with IIT rookie
for this program I'll explain more about
that as we get into the presentation
sure
you're recording
recording in progress
so again we are talking about
the business analyst analytics program
with IIT rookie in collaboration with
IBM
simply learned as a delivery partner
today we're going to be asking a few
questions about you along the way we'll
talk about business analytics careers
and what this program offers
and we'll also talk about how this
program gets you ready to work in that
field
and I'll cover the enrollment steps and
we'll have a q a
with
professor
ravesh
avananda so
they'll be joining us in a little while
he has a a little bit of a delay but I
want to introduce him and let you hear
from him just before we get started uh
he is
an associate professor at uh IIT rookie
and the
advisor for this course
let me
share with you a little bit before we
get into the presentation well here's a
little
bit up front from the professor
analyzing data and putting it to work
for your business or organization is an
essential skill for executives today
foreign the new age of leaders and
understand how best you can use
analytics in this business analytics
program
[Music]
associate professor Department of
management studies
welcome to the business analytics for
the Strategic decision making program by
IIT roorkee in collaboration with simply
learn
IIT roorkee ranks among the best
technological institutions in the world
and has played a vital role in higher
Tech education engineering and research
in its 175 years of existence fast track
your career in business analytics in
just six months by mastering the most
in-demand skills techniques and tools
master key skills like our programming
descriptive analytic Predictive
Analytics prescriptive analytics linear
and Logistics regression supervised
learning unsupervised learning
classification and clustering decision
treats random boards data visualization
and more
some key features of this program are
program completion certificate from the
prestigious Indian instruct technology
live online master classes and state of
art curriculum designed and delivered by
IIT roorkee professors
real world
of analytics across multiple domains and
sectors
industry insights through master classes
by Specialists from IBM
practical exposure through Hands-On
projects and a Capstone
industry relevant
case-based learning specially designed
for Mid to senior level managers and see
suit executives
this program will easily fit into your
budget and schedule you can access all
aspects of the program from your home or
office and the cost for the same is just
a fraction of the tuition fees and
expenses of an equivalent on-campus
program
what are you waiting for get in touch
with one of our learning advisors who
will walk you through the application
process
[Music]
thank you
foreign
so that is a little bit of a flavor of
what we're going to be talking about
today again the professor will be
joining us shortly
so that you'll be able to ask him your
questions live please put those into the
Q a function in
zoom and I'll be able to get those to
him when he's here and then also if
you're on the streaming services
put your questions into the chat or
comment box
try to get those to him as well
so careers in business analysis and and
this program is designed
to make it possible for someone to work
as a business analyst but also for
someone who is in a management or
executive role
to understand and use the tools of
business analysis directly
business analysis is more essential than
ever why is that because
we've undergone a digital transformation
an unprecedented
rate of change
since the onset of the pandemic
before the pandemic
the world was changing over to a digital
environment
more and more what's happening on our
mobile devices or on our desktops
being done online through software as a
service
and then the pandemic hit
there's a story from an executive at a
Silicon Valley
Venture Capital firm who said you know
if they had asked us to convert everyone
to work from home
before the pandemic we would have told
them it would take six months and 10
million dollars in budget when it
happened
took us three days with no budget
that kind of upheaval has
caused people to do more and more of
their daily living online
work from home perhaps you work remotely
you
engage in non-contact transactions you
do microfinance on your
mobile device
so all of that creates a
flood of data businesses
receive all of that data and need to
make sense out of it
and
that's the job of the business anal so
as that shift has happened the demand
for people who can
make sense of that data and turn it into
relevant business insights
things that management can take action
on
has become
just overwhelming
now if you are a manager and you want to
have those insights understanding the
tools
and having the ability to interpret the
data yourself
is an extremely valuable asset in your
career
this is what the environment is this is
why
this set of skills is so important
um it opens up many career paths if you
were looking to work in the field of
business Analytics
directly the business analysts
work uh on these average salaries but
the the rates go much much higher
um
you do need up-to-date skills
for a business analytics career or to
use business analytics in your other
work
you need to have
analytics statistics both for
descriptive
describing what is going on in the world
prescriptive for giving advice to what
you should do in the future and
predictive look at what may happen in
the future based on past
Trends on DNA analytics data
visualization and storytelling being
able to take the
insights from the data and turn it into
uh concise visual presentations that
senior Executives can understand
um
building dashboards from them to use
and understanding the modeling behind
the techniques all of that is extremely
important
um and it's in
the
set of skills that gives you a
foundation
or doing business Analytics
and either building a career in it or
using it within your own career
I'm going to ask a poll question at this
moment
launch the poll here
if you are on our streaming services you
can put A B C or D into the uh
chowder comment
if you're on Zoom please answer the poll
and
what's kept you from enrolling in a
program of this type up until now
is it because you can't find one that
covers all of those skills that we just
talked about because you don't feel
confident you would get practical
experience you could demonstrate your
skills
because the teaching methods that you've
seen in other programs don't fit with
your style or is it because you can't
find
time in your schedule to do one of those
other programs
I'll leave this open for another 20
seconds I think
we've seen more numbers coming in
and I'll close in five four three
two
one
all right
fairly evenly spread between the
different objections here that the most
common is that you don't feel you get
practical experience that you could use
to show off your new skills and
demonstrate that you can do the work
um
so that's the reason why
we developed this program
IIT rookie and IBM
business analytics for strategic
decision making a six-month program
delivered fully online
um you do not have to travel to any
location to study
can do the program completely from your
desktop from your home from your office
much of it can be accessed from your
mobile device
and it has a comprehensive curriculum
that will go into more detail
um
integrated case studies and Hands-On
projects that allow you to learn by
doing but also to build up a portfolio
of
practical experience that you can show
off
and
online live virtual classrooms weekly
with a live instructor in the class
setting online
you can interact with your peers you can
ask your instructor questions and
you can go through and ask about any
doubts or blockers that you might have
and
you can access the rest of the program
your projects your
review videos recordings of the classes
all of that's available to you 24 7. at
any time that you have available so it
fits into your
own particular schedule and lifestyle
so
I've already done that
Excuse me while I skip over here
the end of all of this you have a
program certificate
issued by IIT rookie that certifies you
have completed the program
satisfactorily that you have the skills
that are transmitted in the program and
you can use that as proof along with
your portfolio of
your capability
you also along the way receive
certificates for the courses within the
program that are run by IBM
the IBM issues you
those courses for the professional
classes that they run
and
IBM also owns hackathons ask me anything
sessions
along with those master classes
you have master classes from IIT rookie
faculty
and
went once you have completed the program
earned your certificate
for an additional six months you'll
receive job assist career assistance
from
simply learning its partner
but if you are looking to um
use your new skills to advance in your
career to a new position we'll be able
to support you with that
so when the professor gets here I'm
going to ask him to talk more about the
institution of course because he knows
more about it than I do
um but IIT rookie is
the um
the seventh Institute of Indian
Institute of Technology it was founded
175 years ago
so it has been
helping people with
Technology and Engineering
many different fields
for almost two centuries now
The Institute now has 8 000 students and
500 faculty
and the department of management studies
ranks number one
nirf ranking in 2020 so
the
uh technology of business analytics
falls under that department
this is a very prestigious institution
to have on your CV
and we're also very proud to partner
with IBM one of the things that
simply learned is focused on and IIT
working is now focused on which is
working with industry sources
to provide Learners with most
current
and practical
skills and information from industry so
IBM actually conducts some of the
classes as we've mentioned courses
you'll see in the curriculum which ones
are done by IBM
see here our programming and python are
both
run by IBM
then they would do the master classes
which are optional and you can choose to
take those ask me anything sessions
hackathons
all of these that give you uh exposure
to Industry practices
what's going on in this industry today
so
now I mentioned the simply learned job
assist
what this is is uh available
specifically to people
learning from India we don't offer it in
other
countries at present for this program
but if you are studying in India you
will have access to
six months of support that consists of
access to educational webinars that we
run
career webinars that we run which are
free and available to you indefinitely
you have the options of different
projects within the program which will
describe and become part of your
portfolio
and you have the formal job assist
services from IIM jobs
that falls into three categories
the first is the exclusive job portal
from IIM jobs which provides
exclusive job listings uh confidential
application
very valuable service and
I happen to think that the
other two parts of the program are even
more valuable one is the resume rewrite
service
uh today's resumes have to fulfill two
functions as you apply for a job
uh especially if you're applying online
your resume will go through an automated
tracking system
the first thing that will happen is an
AI bot
will evaluate your resume compare it to
the job description
filter out your resume if it doesn't
match up in some way not that it has to
match every single thing in the job
description
but it has to be be in the form that the
AI bot can understand pick out your
skills and your experience
and
evaluate those in comparison to the job
description so that's a
process that's maybe unfamiliar to a
number of people
because of the way that the AI Bots work
same time if you've passed that filter
then your resume has to go to a human
being and show up on their screen or on
their desktop
and it has to be in the form that is
attractive to them that catches their
attention so having a resume that serves
both functions
is almost a
art form craft something like that and
this is why this part of the service is
valuable
um because it gives you a chance to work
with a professional writer who will
help you get your resume into a form
that does both of those things
and then the one-on-one interview prep
service
extremely valuable for a similar reason
you have to go through assuming your
resume gets in front of a hiring manager
or a recruiter and they are impressed
with it and want to call you in for
resume
um interviews rather
you'll either go online or even in
person to talk to those people a
telephone online in person you have to
be prepared for all of those types of
interviews you have to be prepared to
handle both
technical interviews about your skills
but also cultural fit interviews
interviews assessing your
personality your work style whether
you'll be
valuable contributor to the organization
so having the ability to work with
interview coaches one-on-one
go through both of those types of
interviews on the different media
platforms
that's really a valuable Service as well
so again you have access to these
services for six months after you earn
your certificate I mentioned the
webinars we do various webinars in
different
um
types of environments
and
we do some of them that are of
evaluations of state of the industry we
do some that are career advice we do
some that are job search advice and we
do some that are basically short
one-hour courses on a particular
technical topic so all of these are free
and available to you
uh at your discretion and definitely
and then we talk about the projects and
here are several different choices of
projects that you might do within the
program
you might look at for example the
product mix optimization problem
so that you can
solve the problem for a real world type
application of
choosing the optimal set of project
products for a company to offer or you
might look at customer segmentation
or consumer consumption trends
you would
be given one of these problems based on
a real world situation in
asked to implement
the solution and this is what you're
going to learn how to do in the program
we talk about this
program and what you need in order to
succeed
the main thing that you require is a
real drive to apply business analytics
Concepts
um to real world problems so you need to
to be
essentially fascinated with
how to interpret data and how to drive
insights from them
refer that you have at least six years
of experience in the workplace
that does not mean six years of business
analytics experience it just means six
years of experience in the actual
workplace
um this is so you understand
what the requirements of an organization
are for
day-to-day operations so you'll have
some insights into how business analysis
fits into that
you do not have to come into the program
with any prior technology or coding
experience everything you need to learn
with in that regard you'll learn within
the program itself so
um
given that these are the prerequisites
and it's designed for people who have a
working background and
um
don't have to be technical
I'm going to ask
another poll question from them a
how many years of experience do you
currently have and I'm going to
if I can
get that poll started
a second
there we go
and we'll let that run for
about 20 seconds or so
again if you're on the social channels
please put ABCD
close in five seconds
your answer is in please
all right
ending the pole
so a broad range of experience we have
about uh almost a third of our audience
are people who are still studying
um
but we have also a third of our audience
or people with more than five years of
experience
um
people in that latter category are the
ones
uh most likely to be ready for the
program at this point
good for us to have that feeling from
the audience so thank you appreciate
that
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
the program prepares you
see hold on a second
but my colleague Mohan George on and
I'll be able to ask him
a few questions along the way but in the
meantime
um let's start with the curriculum and
how the program builds your skills step
by step
the orientation session is the first
module of the program
that gets you
um grounded in how the learning
management system works where to find
your courses how to log on to your live
classes
how you keep track of everything where
your reminders come from how you get
into the
community
Forum with your fellow Learners how you
contact your instructors where you find
the resources for doing your coursework
and where you find the
um
the platform environment for doing your
tests or projects all of that that's
covered in the orientation session and
then you move on to
your first class which gives you the
grounding and foundations of data
analytics the principles behind it
um
we move on from that to a statistical
methods that are used in business
decision making so we understand
how modeling is done for different
purposes different types of data how to
fit the
correct model to the data
then you start looking into our
programming this is where you start
working with um
I mean I'm learning how to use the r
language how to do data analysis with
that tool where you start working
to to find actual insights through
data analysis itself
you would have been to predictive
analysis for business
which looks at how to
um derive predictions from past data
using statistical methods and say
if given what has happened in the past
this is what's likely to happen in the
future
from predictive analysis
you move to prescriptive Analytics
prescriptive analytics allows you to do
what-if modeling
and determine what types of actions one
would take to get the outcome one
desires based on the data models
um
finally there's a module on
business
decision making using machine learning
and other data science principles
this is an extremely important new topic
in the industry being able to um
understand how machine learning models
work and how these tools can help you uh
process a much higher volume of data
because the machine will be doing a lot
of the
work that would otherwise have to do
manually
um
and then you'll be able to from that and
also understand what types of insights
machine learning can give you that might
be impractical for a human to do
unassisted
um and finally
Capstone project ties all of these
modules together so Capstone project you
choose again one of the
Real World style industry problems
that you might have to face in your own
work
and you spend three to four weeks
crafting the solution for it under the
mentorship of
your instructor who will meet with you
weekly and help keep you from
running into any blockers or doubts
being able to stay on track
come up with your solution
that you have built yourself becomes
part of your permanent portfolio and
also becomes essentially the final exam
for the entire program
along the way as you can see of
electives which are all
included in the price of the program
choose to take them at your
discretion based on your level of
interest and time commitment
and these include academic master
classes from IIT rookie
these include industry master classes
from IBM
data analysis with python
courses in a
an elective for people who want to get
deeper into programming mathematical
optimizations for business problems
understand the
the physical and mathematical principles
behind those and data visualization
you will learn
various tools and Frameworks maybe
you'll learn them you'll learn them
because you'll be using them in your
projects and coursework
uh so that by the end of the program
you will have practical examples of how
you've used each of these tools and
applied it and you'll have the
confidence to know that you can use that
in your future work
so things like Excel and Tableau
Python and R so
these are just some of the tools that
you'll use during this program
and as I mentioned before the Capstone
project
Captain Capstone project is extremely
important
Capstone project is your uh
best proof of your completion of the
program and your ability to use the
skills that you've learned
and it's something that goes into your
portfolio for permanent future reference
that you can show off to
uh your current or future employers so
this is how you
translate the skills you've learned into
real world practical experience
I'm going to share with you this brief
description
that shows how the learning management
system works
and some of the reasons why IIT rookie
chose us as a delivery partner so you'll
see an example of another program from a
different University in the digital
marketing domain
the principles of how the platform works
are the same
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports on the audience if you notice
are demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running
you could do it on social media later
you'll learn social media marketing too
by looking at these numbers you'll be
able to understand the age range of
people that
are targeting you know what you could
just focus only on that age category
show your advertisements to them very
useful that's not all you get to learn
from faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes ask
your questions to top industry leaders
in exclusive ask me anything sessions so
other interesting question on the chat
box and say that oh to optimize in
YouTube you could use the rising section
of Google Trends and optimize it okay so
let's go back to here right here where
it says web searches and you can see
that there's going to be the YouTube
searches okay so now you can see that
the YouTube searches is going to be so
there's a option uh under not just web
search and there's going to be a YouTube
search okay so just go ahead and click
on YouTube search and you should be able
to optimize your search results
so what is Instagram app Instagram apps
referred to when we come across any sort
of original video
apps would appear within those video
contents so you would be caught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
link
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can showcase
to Future employers your learning isn't
restricted to just live classes explore
our highly effective self-learning
videos and other resources to fine-tune
your learning and remain up to date
always you can focus on different
learning approaches by subject to
personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
all right and so we've
got given you a brief overview of the
learning environment you saw a little
bit about how you manage your curriculum
see all the courses that comprise the
program uh keep track of which ones you
have completed and what's coming up next
you saw a little bit about the live
virtual classroom environment
learning
management system will give you a
calendar and reminders about your
upcoming classes
seeing perhaps a little bit there about
the way to do your labs and projects
within the platform so you don't need to
worry about switching between systems
how to do this tests and assessments
along the way to show that you're
progressing through and unlock each
stage of the program
progress traffic
progress tracking that shows how far you
are in each course and how far you are
in the entire program
and unlocks each stage
including once you've completed the
Capstone project locking your final
certificate from IIT rookie
and a little bit about the support tools
about being able to
communicate with your peers in the
community chat you being able to contact
us 24 7.
for questions about either the platform
itself or about the subject matter
so that gave you an overview of the
learning environment
and
double check to see what time it is
okay
I'm expecting Professor uh Ramesh to be
joining us
he is uh the leader for the program
associate professor in the department of
management studies Professor Sharma is
the assistant professor
of operations
in the same Department
professor
pakee is the assistant professor in
Department of management studies and
also works in operation research Supply
chains issues and that type of thing so
these
professors will be
working with you conducting the master
classes
and overseeing the curriculum
now
I'll briefly stop sharing I want to
check something
we have
on the second let me see if I can
check on the professor here
okay
one moment please
uh he should be joining us shortly
let's move on
there we go
all right let's talk a little bit about
learner outcomes
so here is a
brief testimonial from someone who
learned it my Cricket long experience in
the business development sector has made
me realize you must know how to analyze
data and statistics to grow in your
career I plan to use the business
analytics strategic decision making
course which I did from IIT roorkee and
simply learned to pursue the Senior
Management roles
I have 12 years plus of experience in
business development currently I'm
planning to launch my own startup with
my friends recently I realized the
importance of data analytics for making
business decisions when I started my
career that technology was not Advanced
and data is not readily available but
now it is I have also realized that
companies are looking for people with
the knowledge of machine learning so I
decided to choose a professional
certificate before choosing simply learn
I look for other platform too but the
course simple line provides covers
everything the association with IIT
roorkee makes the certification
internationally recognized in fact my
channel is simply learned began when I
took a course from skill up and I was
really impressed it made me confident
about choosing this course my experience
with simply learn has been amazing the
course is comprehensive and covers
subject of my interest it has R it has
python it has SQL but also something I
have always wanted to learn now I think
I'm ready to make a new beginning
I am going to change my domain from
Business Development to Big Data
learning and Analysis I am looking
forward handling project and
handling the profit profit and loss of
my organization I believe the learning
from the course will be very beneficial
there I wanted to be in a Senior
Management role and I believe this
course will help me to get there I want
to thank my wife who has been very
supportive throughout my journey I am
happy that we have such an amazing
platform which actually quench my thirst
of learning you should never stop
learning
all right
so
just heard from one of our
program
graduates
based on everything you've heard so far
presentation today
and I ask
are you interested in enrolling in this
program just based on what you've heard
so far
and for the people on the streaming
services just put a or b yes or no into
the
chat or comment
leave this open for another
15 seconds
a chance to get your answers in
and we'll close in five
four
three
two
one
ninety percent of the people responding
said that they're interested which is
fantastic I will share with you the
process for doing that
on
enrollment steps are very
straightforward
um contact us at simply learn we
administer the enrollment process for
IIT workkey
you send the email to us at ask us
simplylearn.net I will put that
email address
and the link to the
program web page into the chat for you
so it's available
foreign
that's there in the chat
so you send us that information
um we will ask you some questions about
your interest in the subject your
aptitude
your work experience and
based on those answers we will review
your app review your application and
offer you admission
so the next class cohort starts
with an orientation on the 10th week
and the classes themselves start
on the 25th of February
um
cost of the program is a total of one
lock forty nine thousand
uh it can be financed with
no cost financing over time so
financing is just under 5 000 rupee a
month
and that continues of course until it's
paid off but
uh if you are employed
um ask your employer about tuition
reimbursement if this is something that
applies to your current work
and find out if your company has a
policy for
reimbursing tuition some do
um
they do that can help you with the cost
of the program
so again contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net to get the process
started
we'll ask one more poll question
this one is for those of you who are
interested now that you know more about
the program
how soon would you want to begin do you
want to get started and cohort that
starts this month
do you want to look maybe at the one
right after or something further down
the road
this helps this question helps us
understand
uh the timing so we can
understand how many seats to offer in
different cohorts time
let this stay open for another five
seconds
please get your answers in
ready
here is the poll result
and
about half of the audience are
interested in the beginning this month
or within the next couple of months
if you're looking to do this further out
please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net now and we will answer
any
questions you have about the program but
we'll also be able to help you stay in
contact with us
so that you hear about future editions
of the IIT rookie program
at this point
I'm going to
see if we can take the
questions I am looking for
a second
there it is
okay
I apologize I don't see where the
professor is
foreign
I'm going to go ahead and take the
questions as best I can
apologize I'm not sure what the delay
has been
kept a professor from coming
first question up will you do we get a
certificate for attending this webinar
um no we don't provide certificates of
attendance for
uh these program preview webinars we do
however for the other webinars that I
mentioned
if you take one of the career building
um
or technology learning webinars that I
mentioned the free webinars we offer we
do provide proof of attendance
certificates for those
we have
question
who asks
very similar Tech terms or Tech names
coming around data engineering
data science data analytics how are
these different or are they pointing to
the same thing I'm kind of this is
really a great question
um
they are three distinct different areas
the umbrella over them all is data
science
as it applies understanding
how to interpret data how to find the
patterns within data
how to model the real world from
data measured from it
and data science
concerns itself with creating models
understanding how what the patterns are
in data building models surround those
patterns and creating the algorithms to
extract that information according to
those models
so there's a certain theoretical aspect
to it and a practical aspect to it and
it concerns itself with understanding
data analytics takes the models and
turns and uses them for practical
purposes so in data analytics you take
models
um that are
built by data scientists or suggested by
data scientists and given to you in a
repertoire Library
and as a data analyst you apply those
models to data and
come up with the insights and tell the
story
that the data is giving you so that's
the analytics side either engineering is
a practical skill that Bridges the two
because in order to
run data analytics correctly and in
order for
data scientists they have data sets that
give them information rather than noise
the data engineer Works to create
techniques and procedures that condition
the data clean the data gather the data
extract the data so that
um the raw information coming in from
sensors from transactions from all of
the data points in the real world it
turned into
um data sets that can be used by the
models and machine learning algorithms
so those are the three different aspects
the three different skills
and you can study
any one of them or all three of them in
sequence
these programs are available so
um
Rohan asks do we need to devote a full
six months to this program
or can you pursue it along with your
regular routine of college or job
now that is a great question Rohan
because the answer is that you
definitely can pursue it along with your
existing routine we designed the program
specifically
so that you would be able to do it by
dedicating about 10 to 15 hours per week
um which most people can find alongside
their current
schooling or job
and
much of that is the classes that are on
the weekends or evenings
um so that you
have those scheduled outside of working
hours
you do have to dedicate the period of
six months you have to be willing to say
I will show up to classes each week for
the next six months
with the exceptions of course if you
miss a class it'll be recorded so you
can catch up but you do have to make
that commitment of time
um but it's again
10 to 15 hours a week not
40 or more hours a week full-time on
this program so
that's the reason we designed it this
way is so that people who are working or
studying can
take up new skills and new capabilities
without interrupting their current life
um
looking at this from santu as well
the other programs offer similar types
of other institutions offer similar
types of programs we we feel that the
advantage of this program uh is twofold
number one you're you're working with
IIT rookie
which is an institution that has been
providing uh technology education
for learners for over 175 years
extremely highly ranked
institution but also that you're working
with simply learn and are
learning management system our Boot Camp
style program
there's a reason why IIT rookie chose us
to help them offer this and there's a
reason why
people choose this program over others
and that's because the program is
comprehensive it's flexible it allows
you to complete the program in
conjunction with your your existing life
and lifestyle
and it
provides you with
comprehensive practical experience so
another question in this
period of downturn in the text that
there how will the course be relevant
useful for participants
that is probably the questions on
everyone's mind
and
the
reason that this program is useful
in this particular environment even as
we perceive this downturn in the tech
sector what you're really seeing is the
churn between different companies
Vector so
um
you see where some companies
were as say fat and happy because they
thought that their
growth curve was
only pointing one way which was up
and so they overstaffed
and
end up with
news about
large tech companies laying off staff
well
they do that to become more efficient
but they tend to lay off
uh staff jobs rather than
line or operational jobs and
data analysis
uh
in many instances as an operational job
it's essential to the functioning of the
organization
so
um
that's one aspect where those jobs are
more secure than people who are
peer management or other backgrounds
second aspect is that as I mentioned the
world has transformed
become much more digital much more
quickly in the last several years
so more and more companies understand
that they have to deal with data and
they have to come up with insights from
that data in order to stay competitive
and survive so
they need people
who have these skills if you are in a
staff job as I mentioned
one way to help make your job more
secure is to get more of these skills so
that you can be the one person on staff
who understands how to
interpret the data and present
stories management
that gives you the advantage over your
peers and protect you from
that next round of layoffs but the
better answer of course is that it's
equipping you for the next time
um the economy turns up but also for the
people who in this type of environment
take advantage of the upheaval and start
new companies so
um
if you recall Facebook launched in 2009
during the
worst Global recession of recent memory
so you see that
when one industry starts to change one
company starts to decline others take
its place and take advantage of that
chaos and
you can position yourself to
rise with the new Rising companies
um
one of our attendees I have only one
year of experience should I not do it I
would contact our learning consultants
and ask
I have a conversation with them about
your background your capability and your
commitment if you have a year of
experience that has given you a good
foundation in how your organization
Works where data is needed then
uh
and if you have a keen interest in in
the area know how it's going to to
impact and benefit your career uh this
may be a great program for you even if
you only have the one-year experience
again
um have that conversation with the
learning Consultants
and make sure that it is the right
program for you before making the
commitment
what is the fee structure we've covered
the fee structure you have the ability
to um
do zero cost financing over time cover
the the entire program cost
if you want to proceed for a master's
program how long will it take after the
certificate that would be an independent
if you're looking at a
Masters of Science degree
um that would be where MBA degree that
would be a separate discussion so this
program is
um
a good set of skills to have for that
but it's not
associated with the master's program
directly
um and if the professor were here I
would have him answer the question about
whether
or what Master's programs the uh iiq
rookie offers
can I enroll this course after six
months again I think if you're talking
about six months of uh experience
definitely have that conversation
with our uh learning Consultants
how will this course be beneficial for a
digital strategist
so I would I I hope I interpret the term
digital strategist correctly
but in any type of role where you're
looking at trends for the future
if you're looking at strategies that
companies can follow
to adapt to those Trends it's really
important to have
insights into Predictive Analytics
because you want to be able to look at
real world data
see what the state of the industry and
the state of the business is
and then
be able to make
inferences and predictions from that
data so
it gives you more much more credibility
as a strategist
a person setting strategy for the future
if you are able to back up your
observations and predictions
with solid data analytics
uh an author asks I am a retired
LLC employee and middle level uh
administration business would be and you
this could be a new domain business
Analytics
uh is the course helpful if you have uh
long experience in industry and in
business and you have especially domain
knowledge in particular Industries or
generalist knowledge that you can apply
across Industries because you're an
expert in something like
Finance or that type of thing uh yeah
absolutely this is a course that can be
very useful to you because
again it gives you
um
more credibility and more power behind
your uh
advice and insights and the work that
you do if you can
cite solid data analytics and why the
data is saying
that your advice and your predictions
are correct
um are there guaranteed calls from
companies for hiring this program the
answer is there's not a guarantee
again we work with you uh through IIM
jobs
for those of you in India
and we provide you with support to find
those jobs
where to look
um how to prepare your resume and your
CV for
the best opportunities of getting
through to the hiring managers and we
prepare you for the interview process
but we do not make any guarantee that
you will get calls or get hired
that really depends a lot on your level
of effort that you put into your job
search
okay Priyanka asks in real time data
stored in many different sources
to model the data do we need a lot of
coding knowledge
and that's an interesting question
Priyanka you do not have to have coding
knowledge a lot of what you'll learn in
the course is how to extract data from
different sources
with low code or no code methods that
create data connectors between where the
data comes from and
how you use it so being able to set up
connectors that
allow data from a particular source to
flow real time into a system
and be analyzed on a continuing basis
that's the kind of thing that you'll
learn some of that may involve coding
um
if you choose to take it to that level
this is why we offer with IBM the r and
python
courses
but again you can do much of this work
without having
the depth coding knowledge
and
Naval asks what is the maximum age and
experience limit sign up for this
program
how does the industry look on a person
with 15 years experience and 43 years of
age
um
I can tell you that I am
from a from a point of view of someone
who is
much more than 43 years of age and much
more than 15 years of experience
um
the age of the individual is not a
negative factor
if you have the ability to do the work
demonstrate that you are capable of the
work that you do great work that you put
in the effort to make it all happen
uh the fact that you have 15 or more
years of experience
um gives you insights into how
organizations work and perhaps how a
particular domain works that are
difficult for other people to to match
um
there
the disadvantage of someone who is
not experienced
who doesn't have that background is that
they may not have seen as many examples
of what happens in that industry or what
happens in that field as you have and
may not understand what the business
motivations for a particular set of
analytics is so
um I do not believe you should be
worried about any maximum age limit or
experience limit
can contact our
our learning Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net
they will be able to advise you on that
but again I
it hasn't been
an issue
four people in technical Fields where
they can demonstrate that they have
skills and especially if you've
demonstrated that
by taking a course of this type
you've kept your skills uh up to date
and current so you're not just resting
on
your past experience but you're actively
engaged
sure that you have
current and modernized experiences
take a look here
and
those are all of the questions I have
seen so far
I apologize again
that the professor was not able to join
us
and
at this point I'm going to ask one last
question for the audience
but for those of you who have said oops
excuse me
that you're interested in starting the
program
do you need assistance from us in
getting started
Republicans
this pole
and we'll leave this open for just a
short period
okay
let's get your answers in the next five
seconds
and
and here we go
so just a little more than half you say
that you would like some assistance
please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net for that if you're
confident that you can
enroll without
um
technical assistance please contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net and we will
get you started
that
I want to thank everyone who joined us
today
the QR code will take you straight to
the program
uh information page
on our website
and
of course you've seen the ask us at
simplylearn.net
email address
so on behalf of IIT rookie and simply
learn I want to thank you all for being
here
thank you for your time and we want to
welcome you into the IIT rookie and
simply learn learning community
that concludes our webinar thank you so
much